Jordan peterson,
psychology professor at the University
of Western Ontario,
but no,
University of Toronto.
I'm been there,
uh,
some years a SAF Scott involved because
we,
uh,
we were sent the letters that,
Dr Peterson's Dean and then a vice provo
I believe,
uh,
had sent him and uh,
they,
uh,
they worried us so tremendously as,
as,
as people concerned about academic
freedom and the integrity of teaching.
Um,
the,
uh,
the letters warned Dr Peterson,
to stop saying publicly that he would
refuse requests to use a non gendered
or,
um,
you know,
additional pronouns.
Um,
and this is,
uh,
for us.
So it was a very serious matter very
seriously in an incursion on the freedom
of teachers to teach as they will.
Teaching has a lot to do with the
rapport between the professor and the
student between a classroom dynamics and
the honesty and sincerity that to
teaching requires we thought were
infringed by,
by these orders and especially orders
coming from,
uh,
from deans and department to department
heads.
Um,
and,
uh,
so we wrote letters,
to a University of Toronto about this.
So we're very privileged to have Dr
Peterson with us today to talk to us
about these things.
Um,
maybe also a,
some more theoretical and abstract
things.
Then his own their particular case.
He's going to talk to us about why
freedom of speech is not just another
value.
Peterson.
Thanks.
So I thought I'd start.
I'm going to approach this from three
directions,
but I are in three sections.
I thought I'd start by just letting you
know why I was objecting specifically to
build [inaudible].
Um,
I made three videos in late September
and uh,
one of them criticized,
built see 16 and one of them criticize
the University of Toronto
Administrations,
the human resources peoples decision to
make so called anti unconscious anti
bias training,
mandatory for their HR staff,
which I thought was and still think was
reprehensible.
And uh,
I
don't even remember what the other one
was about,
but it doesn't really matter.
Those are,
that was the first one,
the one on bill [inaudible] that caused
most of the fewer surprisingly enough.
And I said I wouldn't use the made up.
What I consider you a isms that purport
to describe the status,
the status of people whose sexual
identity is ambiguous because that isn't
how it looked to me.
It looked to me like these words like
CSI and xer and so forth were the
linguistic vanguard of a intellectual
movement that I would say detest is
probably the right description and
that's strange blend of postmodernism
and Marxism that has emerged to occupy
the bulk of the humanities and a good
chunk of the social sciences,
and so that was the first thing is that
I'm not using those words.
That was the first thing that was
personal,
right?
Is that that's not a form of linguistic
game that I'm willing to play and I have
my reasons for that.
The second was I regard the ledge.
Any legislation that compels people to
use a certain kind of language as a very
dangerous,
first of all,
dangerous piece of legislation directly,
but also a very dangerous precedent.
I mean,
there are limits on free speech that are
already reasonably well instantiated in
the law.
You can't incite a crime.
You can't threaten someone bodily and
unbelievable manner.
You can't libel someone we already have
reasonable restrictions on,
on what you can't say,
but we've never had legislation that
required you to use a certain language
except in certain commercial
applications.
So for example,
if you sell tobacco,
you have to put a warning on it.
But,
um,
the United States Supreme Court decided,
I believe it was in the 19 forties,
that similar attempts to compel speech
on the part of individuals in
noncommercial settings was
unconstitutional.
And,
and,
uh,
I know that that doesn't have any direct
bearing on Canadian law,
but certainly the principal does.
And then I was also very see,
one of the problems with a piece of
legislation,
and this is,
I suppose the problem with interpreting
a text as the postmodernists would say,
is that it's not easy to get the level
of interpretation right,
right.
Because you're interpreting a text.
You can look at the,
you can look at the letters that happens
with biblical interpretation.
Very often you can look at the
individual words,
you can look at the phrases,
you're going to get,
the sentences,
you can look at the paragraphs,
you could look at the work as a whole,
and then you also have to look at the
context within which the work is being
interpreted in order to come up with an
interpretation of anything that's
complex.
And so when you see a piece of
legislation,
it isn't obvious what the legislation is
actually intended to do despite what
it's purported to do.
And it isn't obvious what level of
analysis to pick when you're going to
criticize it.
And in some ways bill [inaudible],
you could regard it as innocuous just as
an extension of rights that have already
been granted to certain,
let's say,
protected groups.
Although I'm not so thrilled about the
whole notion of ascribing rights to
groups to begin with.
We're already far down that path.
But,
um,
and you know,
I've been accused of making a mountain
out of a mole hill,
but happily enough,
the University of Toronto,
after I made the videos,
immediately produced two letters that
were informed by their legal
departments.
Wisdom,
I'm stating that what I had done with
the video was perhaps in conflict with
the university ethical guidelines,
if you forget the ones that had to do
with freedom of expression and that they
might,
that my actions and even in making the
video might have violated that the
tenants of the Ontario Human Rights Act
as it's or they at least as it's
interpreted by the Ontario Human Rights
Commission.
And so that helped put to rest any
suggestion that I was actually
scaremongering because as soon as I,
as soon as I made the videos,
the legal department at the uft
immediately validated my fears.
And so that was a perverse,
was a perverse effect of their,
of the letters they sent to me.
So,
um,
the other thing that I,
there was other elements of the
legislation that I object to and
objected to and still do.
And if you read the policies within
which the legislation will be
interpreted as the federal justice,
a website indicated that it would be
interpreted in within the policies that
the Ontario Human Rights Commission is
already established.
Of course there's close cross talk
between Ontario and the federal
government because the liberals are in
power in both and the radical end of the
liberal party's in power in both
situations and know it.
It turns out that it's illegal for like
you're liable as an employer.
For example,
if any of your employees say anything
that can be construed as harassment,
say on the grounds of sexual
or gender identity,
even if what they say has unintended
consequences and even if you don't know
that they said it.
And so that kind of legislation I just
think is just absolutely reprehensible
and then because it's designed to cast
the broadest possible net to catch the
most fish and it's clearly being
implemented by people who are not
precisely pro employer.
Let's put it that way.
And then there's another little ugly
secret hidden underneath the policies
and that's manifests most clearly in the
form of what's come to be known as the
Gender Unicorn.
Which I would recommend that you look
up,
which is an animated character designed
to indoctrinate small children into the
social constructionist worldview.
Which claims that biological sex,
gender identity,
gender expression,
and sexual proclivity very
independently,
which they most certainly do,
not now.
And that's what I said in the video.
That's partly why I've been accused of
say,
being a transphobic.
I also complained that the university
was taking policy advice from the people
who started black lives matter.
And I don't have anything against black
lives matter particularly,
but the two people who started it are,
are not,
uh,
this sorts of individuals,
let's say that the university should be
basing its policy decisions that the
advice they shouldn't be taking advice
from those people with regards to their
policy.
And apparently that makes me a racist.
So the first part of the argument about
what happened with my videos was
actually whether or not I was racist and
Trans phobic and all of that.
But the point that I was making the
technical,
specific technical point was that the
claim that,
uh,
those four phenomena very independently
was just patently false.
And it is by any reasonable definition
of false.
And I know that it's part of a much
broader propaganda exercise as evidenced
by the Gender Unicorn,
for example,
which gets children to indicate on four
sliders their sex assigned at birth,
their gender identity,
their gender expression,
and their sexual proclivity.
And you can look at the animation and,
or at the,
at the cartoon and decide for yourself
by its graphic style,
what Ange people it's aimed at.
So,
um,
is this a bill to protect transexual
rights?
Or is it a bill to further a postmodern,
Neo Marxist agenda?
Well,
God only knows,
but as far as I'm concerned,
having analyzed the context within which
this bill arose and within which it will
be interpreted,
I'm going to go for the furthering the
postmodern Neil Marxist agenda until
I'm.
Until that's thoroughly disproved.
I would also like to inform you that
I've had plenty of letters from
transgender people,
at least 30 and only one of them was
critical of what I'm doing because they,
they claim and as happy as have many of
the people I've talked to that the idea
that a group of activists self can self
nominate as the representatives of a
given group and then speak for them as
if they have a homogenous voice is
absolutely absurd.
And it is.
It is completely ridiculous.
And most of the transsexual people that
have been contacting me have said the
same thing,
which is these people don't speak for
me.
I wish they'd shut up because they're
doing a lot more harm than good and I
don't buy what they're doing anyways.
So,
you know,
I think that the claim of the activist
types to speak on behalf of the groups
that they purport to represent is weak
at best.
And I don't know why we ever assumed
that it,
it,
that their representation is valid
except that we're afraid to criticize
that particular presupposition.
You know?
I mean,
there's nothing more ridiculous than
assuming that someone is.
Because someone is black that they speak
for black people.
I mean,
I think,
I can't think of anything that's more
particularly indicative of a
fundamentally racist attitude than that,
you know?
Well those people,
they're all the same.
It's like,
yeah,
well,
sorry,
it doesn't work out that way.
So I wanted to clarify all that so that,
you know,
you have a little bit clearer idea about
why I was doing what I was doing and
people have asked so to speak,
why I chose to die on that particular
hale.
And the answer is every,
every massive conflict of ideas,
let's say manifests itself in the
minute.
And that's why it's often difficult to
gain any headway because no matter where
you draw the line,
it's arbitrary.
And,
and subject to criticism and you know,
the fact that this happens to be about,
um,
gender neutral pronouns regarding
transgender people to me is just more or
less an accident.
It would have been about almost any
number of other things.
But I would also like to suggest that
what should have happened with what I
did was nothing.
I made some videos that are on board,
relatively obscure academic and I made
some videos in my private time that were
pretty badly produced because they're
just amateur and I was trying to
straighten out my thinking about a
couple of issues,
the anti unconscious bias training for
example,
and also this legislative mess and
obviously it struck a major chord and
that to me is indication that my
original supposition was correct and
that there was far more going on under
the surface than there was at the
surface.
I mean,
you know,
like I said,
it's very difficult to pick the proper
level of analysis,
but one of the ways you justify your
choices by observing the impact of your
choice of level of analysis and seeing
if it's.
If the consequences are commensurate
with your original hypothesis.
And I thought well just because people
say they're doing one thing with a piece
of legislation doesn't mean that that's
what they're doing.
And of course a lead piece of
legislation is a hydra.
In any case.
It does all sorts of things that people
don't intend it to do.
So that's a little background and I'll
leave the background at that and then
I'll talk to you now from a practical
perspective why I believe that the idea
of freedom of speech is not just another
value among other values.
I would say that the simplest reason for
that is that speech isn't precisely a
mechanism.
It,
it's a,
it's a process.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a generative process.
Speech free speech is the process by
which all ideas are generated and I want
to make it clear why I believe that to
be the case with speech specifically
because you might say,
well no,
that's thought but,
but,
but I don't think that's right.
Because thing is that thought is a far
more collective enterprise than people
generally understand.
First of all,
most of the thoughts you have aren't
your thoughts.
You know,
I don't remember who it was that said
that everyone is the unconscious
exponent of a dead philosopher.
But that's definitely the case.
You know,
are very linguistic mechanisms by which
we formulate our,
our grip on the world,
our collective constructs.
And,
and in some cases almost entirely
because creative thought is far rarer
than people generally presume.
And what that means is that when we're
speaking and when we're thinking we're
usually using,
if not cliches,
which is very frequently the case,
as you know perfectly well if you've
ever a graded a particularly bad
undergraduate essay,
but even among more sophisticated
people,
it's generally the case that they're
acting as avatars of ideas that they did
not produce.
And so that doesn't mean they can't
further the ideas,
but the point is,
is that,
you know,
we're born into a linguistically
mediated culture and it's,
it's mediated at all of the multiple
levels of analysis that I already
described and were shaped in the way
that we view the world with regards to
the input that,
that,
that we received.
That's collective.
We learn language from other people.
We use the words that other people use,
we use the phrases that other people
use.
It's an intensely collective exercise,
but even more specifically.
So that's from a general perspective,
let's say,
but even more specifically,
the problem with thinking is that you're
a very narrow channel,
right?
I mean,
there's a lot of world and there isn't
very much of you and that means that
there's a lot more that you filter out.
Then there is that you take in and
you're filtering is very,
very intensive.
It's dependent to some degree on your
embodiment.
It's dependent to some degree,
far more than people generally realize
on your motivations and your and your
temperament,
which is a topic we'll return to and
then it's further narrowed by your
position in society and by the people
that you have around you and by your
particular domain of expertise or lack
thereof.
Um,
and then there are sets of darker
motivations as well that blind you to
certain things that you should be able
to see but either don't or won't.
And so the problem with thinking is that
a,
you're a narrow channel B,
you're not very good at it and see your
incredibly biased and there isn't much
you can do about that except
listen and talk to other people because
they're,
I mean,
they're not the only source of
correction,
but there are pretty intense source of
correction.
And I mean,
we're blasting corrective information at
each other all the time,
right?
I mean,
even in a situation like this,
which you could think of as a monologue
but isn't.
It's a dialogue.
The reason I'm watching all of you is to
see,
you know,
are you paying attention?
And if not,
I better adjust what I'm saying.
Do your facial expressions,
uh,
indicate that you're understanding what
I'm saying and following it.
Maybe you're nodding your,
your eyes are open,
you know,
in some specific way you're,
you're actually facing me.
Your eyes are on me.
I can read your facial expressions,
which is always why I'm looking at
individuals in the audience.
And I'm constantly calibrating what I'm
saying.
If it's a dynamic conversation to ensure
that the information flow is maximized.
And the reason I look at your eyes is
because I can tell where they're
pointing.
And the reason I look at your face is
because you're broadcasting motivational
and emotional information nonstop at me.
Well,
I'm speaking.
And so even in a situation like this,
which like I said,
is more more analog than,
than otherwise.
There's a tremendous amount of
corrective information continually
flowing between speaker and listener,
and if that stops,
you know,
if,
if you hear a speaker who's detached
from the audience,
often someone who's reading,
for example,
it's much more difficult to listen to
them as everyone knows,
and that's because there's a deadness
about reading something in front of an
audience.
And I think the reason for that is that
that living,
let's call it spirit,
isn't manifesting itself in the same
manner as it is when,
when the speech is both spontaneous and
self correcting.
And so the thing about free speech is
that like I'm not a free speech
advocate.
Let's say I'm a true speech advocate,
which is to say that I believe that
people should say what they believe to
be true.
I think that's.
That's your obligation.
It's also,
you're right,
but it comes with an obligation,
but I don't believe that true speech as
possible without free speech because
you're just not very good at thinking
and so you have to stumble around when
you're first formulating ideas and
wander into territory that's not
necessarily productive and manifest your
biases and in short you have to be a
fool and the only way that you you
improve upon that performances by well
first of all,
stumbling through it to begin with and
then second,
by observing carefully what sort of
reactions you're getting and having a
dialogue around it so that you can start
to sharpen up your ideas and improve
their focus and find out where you've
made a mistake and all of those things.
So a lot of what's necessary with
regards to thinking is the freedom to
make mistakes.
Because what are you going to do it
right the first time?
I don't think so.
And you know,
that's why for Carl Young,
for example,
the fool was a mythological precursor to
the,
to the hero,
the tricksters and mythological
precursor to the hero.
Because unless you're willing to stumble
around badly to begin with,
I want to be a fool.
When you first start doing something
which is always the case.
When you're learning something new,
then you're not gonna make any progress,
and so practically speaking,
free speech has to be as untrammeled as
possible so that people can be wrong and
they can be biased and they can still
express their opinions,
including their darker ones,
and then allow themselves to be subject
partly to improvement by the world
because if you say things that are too
stupid and then act the mouth,
the world smacks you a good one.
But there's also the social
intermediaries,
the other people that you're
communicating with who will also do the
same thing.
You know,
and we're always broadcasting
information at each other.
Constantly trying to shake each other's
behavior.
And what we're trying to do is to bring
forth from other people that which we
would like to see them manifest.
And so there's an implicit ideal as well
that people are broadcasting in each
other all the time.
And there's tremendous social pressure
generally speaking,
to manifest that implicit ideal as
closely as possible because otherwise
people disapprove of viewer lack
interest in what you're saying or
criticize you or and so on.
And you have to be allowed to be exposed
to that kind of corrective feedback
because otherwise you drift and,
and you'll become subject to your own
idiosyncratic insanity.
And I mean,
I,
I've seen that very many times in my
clinical practice because,
well,
first of all,
I have some isolated people that come to
see me and all they do is talk.
I just listen.
I mean because they don't have anyone
else around and they need someone to run
their narrative by,
to keep their minds organized.
They can't do it themselves.
And they can't do it without listening
to themselves talk even because for most
people talking is how they think.
And,
and talking socially is even more how
they think.
And I mean that literally.
I don't mean that metaphorically is
that.
And I think that's true for almost
everyone.
You know,
I mean there are people who are trained
academically who can actually think.
But to think you have to divide yourself
into sub personalities,
I suppose,
each of which has a differing opinion,
uh,
well elucidated differing opinion and
then you have to let those different
elements of your personality have an
internal dialogue and you have to draw
conclusions from that.
It's very,
very difficult for people to do that and
we radically overestimate the degree to
which they do.
I'm young said at one point that people
don't think so much as thoughts appear
in their head and they believe that the,
which I think is a much more accurate
way of describing the,
the general because true thought is not
only that the thoughts arise in your
mind,
it's that you look at the thought and
then you critique it,
right?
You have to separate yourself from the
thought and decide whether or not it's,
it's,
it's valuable.
Now that's more like an editing function
and you know,
it takes a long time to be a good
editor,
a tremendous amount of time and it just
doesn't happen generally speaking so
well.
So I would say,
well without free speech there's no true
thought.
And then you might say,
well,
who the hell cares whether or not we
think?
And I think the answer to that is fairly
straightforward,
mean you might think it's so obvious
that it doesn't need explanation,
but there are very few things that are
so obvious they don't need explanation.
So the reason you think is so that the
world doesn't smack you as hard as it
might fundamentally,
you know,
and,
and I really mean this technically
because the way that people evolved the
capacity to thought for thought was that
the prefrontal cortex which mediates a
lot of,
of,
of voluntary linguistic ability actually
emerged over the course of evolutionary
history out of the motor cortex.
And so that's a very interesting thing
to understand because it means that,
you know,
animals basically think by moving.
And the problem with that is if you
think by moving and you make the wrong
move than your.
Whereas what human beings can do is they
can generate fictional avatars of
themselves in fictional worlds and they
can run the avatars as simulations and
the ones that get killed,
they don't express in behavior.
And I mean,
you could do that with words too,
although people you know originally
would have done it mostly with images.
They do the same thing with drama.
And so the reason that you think,
and I think it was George,
was it Alfred North Whitehead that said
this,
I think,
but I'm not absolutely sure.
The reason you think is so that your
thoughts can die instead of you.
And that's a brilliant,
brilliant,
brilliant phrase and absolutely the
case.
So if you think properly,
then you kill off.
The idea is that if you act it out would
kill you or at least cause you suffering
or perhaps caused suffering to the
people around you.
And since it's more or less obvious,
a priority,
that suffering is worse than not
suffering.
Under most circumstances.
It seems reasonable to act in a manner
that will minimize it to the degree that
that's possible.
And so you need clarity of thought
because that helps guide you through a
world that's in shrouded in fog and full
of sharp objects.
And if you don't want to stumble into
them and impale yourself,
then you should have sharp vision and
sharp capacity to communicate.
You know?
That's one of the things I tell students
when I'm trying to teach them to write
because they no one ever tells them why
they should learn to write.
It's like you learn to write so you can
think and you learn to think so that the
world doesn't treat you any more harshly
than it absolutely has to.
And that's no joke.
You know?
And if you,
if you're a person who's been around a
bit,
you see very rapidly that people who
sharpen their arguments properly and can
articulate their position and defend it
are always,
always the people who are most
successful and most compelling and that
and that changed the way structures
function.
And that also helped things continue in
the proper path when they're running
down the proper path.
It's no joke to be articulate and to be
able to think there isn't anything
that's more powerful than that.
And that's a good segue into the second
or the third part of what I wanted to
talk to you about.
See
since I made those videos,
I've become,
I guess the word is popular on.
Yeah,
well in many ways,
by about November,
by the end of November last year,
there were more than 200 newspaper
articles about the consequences of the
videos that I've produced.
And those were like in press printed
articles.
I'm not talking about anything that
happened on Youtube.
And Youtube is a very strange phenomena.
Let me tell you,
it's a far more powerful than you think.
So just as an aside,
I was on a program last week hosted by a
guy named Joe Rogan.
I don't know how many of you know who
joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan gets one point,
2 billion downloads of his podcast a
year.
You just think about that,
like that's absolutely unparalleled.
And everybody under 30 years getting
their news from either facebook or from
Youtube and the whole conventional media
sources,
they're dead is there are so dead,
you can hardly believe it.
So Youtube,
and one of the reasons I'm bringing it
up is because youtube is the first
platform that's produced for people the
capacity to make the spoken word as far
reaching and permanent as the written
word.
Right?
That's a complete cultural revolution.
It's the first time it's ever happened.
I mean,
it wouldn't have to be youtube,
it just turns out that that's the
platform that got there first,
but it's a big deal.
And anyways,
um,
the,
the reason that,
that,
that my,
that I became popular,
I think was partly because of the,
of the political philosophical videos
that I made.
But then when people came to my website
to watch them,
they stayed generally speaking to watch
the lectures that I had been posting on
there since 2013.
And,
uh,
those were derived from work I did on a
book called maps of meaning,
which I published in 1999.
And see what I was trying to do with
that book was to sort something out that
was very complex.
And that was when I was growing up in
the Cold War was raging.
I couldn't understand precisely why we
had divided into two armed camps around
our respective ideological positions,
either why those ideological positions
were so important that people would risk
the destruction of the world to protect
them,
let's say,
or why it was those two particular
ideologies or whether or not this was
just a difference of opinion.
Right?
Which would be.
That would be a more postmodern view is
there's multiple ways that you can
organize societies in the west.
We happened to organize our society one
way,
but that's one of a plethora of
potential ways of organizing society and
let's say the Communists had decided to
organize their society and other way and
human beings are infinitely malleable
and so you know,
the social structures that we occupy are
arbitrary in some sense and matter of
opinion and maybe collective opinion,
but nonetheless still a matter of
opinion.
And I thought,
well,
is it the case that the values that we
hold to be true in the West are merely
based upon opinion?
And so I started to investigate that and
and the conclusion that I came to as a
consequence of hitting the question from
multiple different perspectives was that
that was not a reasonable way of
formulating,
of,
of interpreting the evidence.
And so I looked at neuroscience evidence
from neuropsychology and neuroscience,
mostly mostly
based,
at least in part on the work of someone
named Jeffrey Gray.
It was a very good psychologist,
very interested in anxiety.
I looked at general behavioral
psychology,
looked at literature,
and I looked at mythology and I could
see a pattern emerging across all of
those,
which I think is a nice way of
determining whether or not something
exists.
Like it's one thing to see a pattern in
one set of data,
but if you can see the same pattern and
another set that's quite historically
distinct from the first and then see the
same pattern in another set and another
set,
then the probability that that's a
spurious pattern starts to decrease
quite radically.
And so I don't think the pattern was
spurious.
And so I'm going to tell you what I
think I.
What would you say extracted?
This is very complicated and makes a
difficult transition in the talk,
so I'm going to read something first.
This is from the,
from the gospel of John.
It's one of the most famous lines in the
Bible.
In the beginning was the word and the
word was with God and the word was God.
It's very strange idea because from a
cosmological perspective,
because it pauses that there's something
I'm conscious or cognitive about the
origin,
that there's a necessary cognitive
element to the origin and I think about
that essentially as something associated
with consciousness and of course we
don't really understand the relationship
between consciousness and being.
We don't understand consciousness at
all,
but it seems integrally associated,
at least with our individual beings
because one of the things that we seem
to not doubt is that we are in fact
conscious and that so are other people
and if I treat someone as if they're not
conscious,
while they tend not to be very happy
about that.
So it will certainly object to it.
So despite what we might say,
we believe,
we certainly act as if we regard all
other human beings as conscious.
And and the consciousness is a
prerequisite for their,
for the existence of their experience.
So
anyways,
so that there's this emphasis in this
book that is at the root of our culture,
that there's something about verbal
communication in particular that has to
be regarded as foundational.
And I think that's actually to some
degree in keeping with the postmodernist
claims that everything is a language
game.
Let's say that everything is constructed
by language.
Now,
I don't believe that everything is
constructed by language,
but I'm just pointing that out because
you can take this particular perspective
and you can look at it from a variety of
different intellectual sources and still
derive an analog of the,
of the claim from it.
So
and then our so that,
that was so.
So I want you to keep that in the back
of your mind for a moment.
Now,
that idea that,
that the word was there at the beginning
of creation,
that's a very,
very old idea.
It's,
it's older than the Judeo Christian.
A context from which I extracted it.
So for example,
in Egypt there was a god named Patah who
was a major.
God,
I may be that wrong,
but as far as the Egyptians were
concerned,
he was the original creator and he
created as a consequence of thinking,
but more specifically as a consequence
of speaking.
So again,
there was this idea that there was this
primacy of speaking as a,
as a force that brings being into
existence and then you see the same
thing in the Mesopotamian context to
their creation.
Myth was called the Enuma elish and
there's a god in that story and that
story apparently is one of the places
from which the creation story in the in
the Bible was extracted that God is
named Martin and Martin is a god that
fights chaos and creates the world out
of the consequences.
And He.
He has a variety of different
attributes.
One of which is head is ringed with
eyes.
So we can see in all directions.
So there's very much emphasis among the
Mesopotamians on the primacy of
attention,
let's say.
But he can also speak magic words and
it's the fact that he's equipped with
this massive capacity for attention and
the ability to speak magic words that
enables him to go and fight the dragon
of chaos,
roughly speaking into cutter into pieces
and make up the world.
One of [inaudible] names,
for example,
is he who makes ingenious things out of
the combat with ty Matt and time at is
this got primordial goddess of chaos
that represents the sort of the formless
prodo matter of things from which
consciousness extract structure.
That's one way of thinking about it.
So that idea is quite widespread.
It's a very,
in fact,
it's an idea that informs mythological
structures everywhere as far as I can
tell.
There's this idea that there's a dynamic
between what you know and what you don't
know.
You can think about those as different
domains of reality,
what you know and what you don't know,
and the thing that mediates between what
you know and what you don't know is this
thing that has the attribute of have
spoken wisdom.
It's something like that.
And here's,
here's a way that's a very complicated
idea.
It's very difficult to understand.
It's extraordinarily difficult to
understand,
but the,
I can give you some sense of it.
It's a phenomenal logical idea.
I suppose.
Imagine that you are,
that um,
I don't know.
Maybe you have it.
Yeah.
Maybe you're a medical student,
a medical premed students,
right?
Do you want to go to medical school?
And so you're easily beating away on
your,
on your courses.
You're doing all right.
You know,
then you go take them cat and you score
it the say 20th percentile,
which of course 20 percent of people do.
And that will come as quite a shock to
you,
no doubt,
because you go in there in the world
that you understand and in that world,
your competence,
let's say to become a medical doctor and
when you open the envelope and you look
at the number then,
well then your world crumbles and
collapses and collapses into,
I would say is equivalent to this
formless chaos that the ancients
believed was the ground of being.
And it's this place where reigns,
right?
In fact,
the word for the chaos that God orders
with the word at the beginning of
genesis is often translated as chaos or
confusion now and you think,
well,
you've formulated a world that you
inhabit with a particular linguistic
rational,
logical structure.
It's predicated on certain axioms of
belief like that you're competent to be
a medical doctor and then you receive a
piece of information that makes not only
your present understanding of yourself,
no longer relevant or correct,
but also your past understanding of
yourself and also your future who've
gone right or gone were gone into what
well gone into chaos roughly speaking,
and then you're in very rough shape as a
consequence of that,
and if you do manage to lever yourself
out of that chaotic condition that you
now find yourself in,
you're going to essentially do it with
thought and dialogue,
right?
Because you're going to talk to people,
what did I do wrong?
What's wrong with the way I thought?
How could I have been so misled by what
I believe?
What should I do now?
Who actually am I?
All of that is a way of reconstructing
yourself from the ashes,
so to speak.
I would say that,
and you do that with,
with,
with speech,
and you do that with true speech and so
true speeches,
what,
what redeemed you from the chaos of
unstructured being and so,
so then that.
That's another thing to think about for
a moment and then I'm going to bring up
this final piece and
we can think about it too.
So
I've been trying to figure out how these
ideas came to be because they came to be
over a very long period of time.
So the God Marduk for example,
he was assembled,
you could say as the empires of the
ancient Middle East,
as the tribal people of the ancient
Middle East came together and they each
had their own daddies that represented
their highest values and when they came
together those deities had to be
amalgamated and so try bay has its
highest value and try B has its highest
value in their embodied.
That's the day of the element and they
come together and then the day at east
in some sense have to have a war to
figure out who's the top God and so if
you assemble a few hundred tribes out of
that comes a conceptualization of the
top God that was Marduk,
for example in Mesopotamia,
and he usually absorbs the names of all
the previous gods as he sort of emerged
as the king of a hierarchy.
And so so you think about this.
If you think about the expression of the
daddy as the projection of the highest
ideal of the tribe,
and that's something that's been worked
out over perhaps millennia and
especially with people who have an oral
tradition and then you bring those
different tribes together.
What happens is the highest ideals in
their embodied form have what you could
think of metaphorically as a war,
and the war of God's in heaven,
by the way,
is a very ancient and widespread
mythological motif.
And out of that war arises what you
might describe as a matter of value.
And so the metta value would be the
highest value among a set of values.
And the question would be,
what,
what would that value be?
What would that highest fail you be?
Is there something about it that's,
that's recognizable and say somewhat
constant so that if you took 100 tribes
here and amalgamated their ideals and
you took 100 tribes here at amalgamated,
their ideals,
if the two sets of amalgamations would
have a structural similarity to one
another.
And as far as I can tell the answer to
that is yes.
And it's a logical answer because you'd
expect structural similarity if you
extract out a common,
um,
a common element from a very large
number of constituent representatives.
So for example,
if you take a,
a large number of female faces and
average them.
So I'm not talking about the average
face,
I'm talking about the averaged face.
It's not the same thing.
The averaged female face is attractive
and so is the average male face.
And so because it kind of constitutes
the central human form and if you take
64 women and you extract out an average
face and you take another 64,
you get the same face,
well maybe it takes more than 64,
but you get the point.
And so.
Well,
so I was,
I was thinking about how that process
came to be.
I decided to look at it,
even like to go back farther in time to
try to understand how it is that we
formulated our values per se.
And especially given that at some point
we weren't linguistic creatures at all.
Right?
We separated from the common ancestors
between us and chimpanzees about 6
million years ago.
And sometime during that 6 million year
process we started to be able to imitate
ourselves first and then represent
ourselves in image and action.
And then only after that to start to
articulate ourselves.
And so a lot of the knowledge that we
have is grounded in our embodiment,
but also in the shaping of that
embodiment across extraordinary long
periods of time.
So like there's an implicit way of being
in your form,
in your embodied form,
but more importantly,
there's an implicit way of being that's
a consequence of the fact that we've
existed within hierarchical social
structures for far longer than we were
even sharing a common ancestors say with
great apes.
So that's for maybe hundreds of millions
of years with regards to being embedded
in a hierarchy.
So then the question is something like,
well,
for embedded in a hierarchy and we have
been forever,
that's about $350 million years,
by the way,
is there a set of attributes that tends
reliably to move you up the hierarchy?
Because if there is,
you see being going up the hierarchy
increases the probability of
reproductive success.
So there's actually nothing more
important to determine over the course
of $350 million years inside a
hierarchy.
Then how it is that you ratchet yourself
up the hierarchy reliably and you could
think about that in some sense as the
source of ideals here.
Here's a kind of a concrete way of
thinking about that.
You know,
if you get 100 men together,
they're going to,
they're going to organize themselves
into a hierarchical structure.
They have to or they're gonna stay
chaotic and fight that.
That's the other alternative and so,
but the the way that that,
that the people who are going to rise to
the top,
they might rise to the top because of
their sheer physical prowess and power,
but they also might rise to the top
because they're very competent at
certain things and it's as if all the
men are going to get together and vote
and maybe that would actually happen to
determine who best embodies the spirit
of the group and who should be granted
leadership and in an evolutionary
context,
by the way,
that would also help ensure that that
person would propagate their genes into
the next generation and it's not a
trivial effect,
especially among men.
It's a big effect because roughly
speaking half half of all manner or not
reproductively successful,
so there's a wicked.
There's a wicked,
a calling,
let's say among men.
Well,
you can see this among chimpanzees as
well.
They have dominance hierarchies.
Some sort of chimps rise to the top and
you might think,
well,
that's the like caveman chimp who's best
at pounding out all the,
all the rivals,
but it turns out that that's not exactly
the case in France to wall has done a
very good job of detailing this with his
work on chimpanzees in particular and
he's found that the power hungry tyrants
sort of chimp can rule for awhile,
but he tends to have a very unstable
kingdom and the reason for that is is
he's not very good at mutually grooming
is not good at socially connecting with
other males and he isn't popular among
the females and doesn't attend to the to
the young essentially.
And so what happens is even if he's like
the meanest,
toughest guy on the block to subordinate
chimps,
team up,
they make friends.
They groom each other and they have each
other's backs and in a one day he's
having an off day because he ate too
many fermented bananas the night before
and like they just tear them into pieces
and chimps are unbelievably strong and
unbelievably brutal.
They seem to have absolutely no internal
regulation whatsoever of the regression
that all seems to be manifested outside
in terms of dominance,
hierarchy control,
and we know that because they go on
raiding parties into other chimp
territories and when they find chimps
that aren't part of their hierarchy,
they just rip them into pieces.
And so that's a scary thing if you think
about our similarity with chimpanzees
because we like to think we have
internal controls over our aggression,
but it's not so bloody obvious I can
tell you that.
Anyways.
What duwall found was that it's actually
chimps that are more,
um,
you might say humane,
although Champaign,
I don't know what the equivalent it is,
let's say humane that managed to produce
hierarchies that are more stable and
actually managed to stay alive on top of
them for much longer periods of time.
And he thinks about that as the
emergence of an implicit morality,
right?
So morality that's acted out.
So then you think,
well,
there,
there are different ways of climbing up
a hierarchy.
There are worse and better ways.
The better ways allow you to live longer
in a more stable hierarchy and the
evolutionary payoff for that is that you
leave more,
more descendants and so the hierarchy
itself becomes a very powerful shaping
mechanism that determines how it is that
people are going to adapt because it's
the primary method of selection,
so there's an ethic in there.
There's an ethic that emerges from the
social interactions,
but that's rapidly transformed into a
biological selection device and so were
selected and that's especially true
among human beings because with chimps,
the females are indiscriminant maters,
which is to say that a female champion
heat will meet with any mail chimp.
Now,
this dominant males chase the
subordinate males away,
so there's still more likely to leave
offspring than the subordinates,
but it's not because of the females,
but human females are different.
Human females exert choice and quite
brutal choice.
You might put it that way.
They're very choosy and it's one of the
things that seems to have distinguished
us from chimpanzees and what roughly
seems to happen is that the male
dominance hierarchy elects men to the
higher say rungs of the hierarchy.
And then the females peel from the top,
and so that means that what you can say
is that human beings are the consequence
of intense male dominance,
competition.
It's not necessarily dominance,
but it's competition for the upper rungs
of the hierarchy mediated by female
selection.
And so that's produced as far as I can
tell,
a powerful,
a powerful pattern of behavior.
Now the question is,
what's that pattern of behavior?
I would say,
well,
it's encapsulated in mythology in two
forms and the question is,
well,
who should lead?
Let's say that's the question.
Who should lead?
That is the question,
who should be sovereign or maybe when it
becomes abstracted,
what should be sovereign?
Because the first question from an
evolutionary perspective is who should
be sovereign?
But once you could abstract,
then the principle of sovereignty can be
detached from the leader and become a
principal all on its own and that might
be first expressed in mythological or
images stick form dramatic form like the
the good guys versus the bad guys are
good versus evil.
We could say it like that,
but obviously it's embodied and acted
out far before it's extracted.
And turned into an abstract
representation.
What would seems to have happened is,
so one of the common themes,
for example in mythology,
is what's roughly been described as a
hero myth.
And a hero myth involves someone who's
part of a,
uh,
demolished community community under
threat.
The threat's usually signified by
something vaguely like a dragon,
and the dragon comes out,
it's eternal.
It comes out to attack the village.
The hero comes out and confronts the
Dragon and then freeze the virgin,
for example,
or gets the gold.
And to me,
that's a very,
very well.
That is a very old story.
It's in the Enuma elish for example.
It's the story at the basis of very
many,
what would you call it?
Widely dispersed myths around the world.
The Dragon,
for example,
is a very common symbol.
And I think the reason for that is it's
so complicated,
but I think the reason for that is
something like this is that human beings
learned to understand over time that the
most reliable leader was the person who
could step outside the structure when it
was damaged to confront something that
was chaotic and dangerous in whatever
form that might be,
and then to bring something valuable
back as a consequence,
and you see that principle being
elevated continually and mythological
stories like the Enuma elish for
example,
where the main hero Marduk is elevated
among the other gods and is
characterized by this intense capacity
for vision which the Greek which the
Egyptians also worshiped in the form of
horace and this capacity to speak which
has this ability to,
to,
to formulate and reshape the world.
Well,
that's the thing is that it's as if what
we've discovered as a species in some
senses,
that there's the the person that should
lead the thing that should be sovereign
is the thing that can step outside the
structured order,
incorporate something new and dangerous,
and then produce something valuable out
of it.
That's one phase.
Another phase is another hero myth is
the person who who,
who criticizes the power elite when it
becomes corrupt and points out the
corruption and then restructures the
society that happens in the prophetic
books,
for example,
continually in the Old Testament because
you could think that the historical
enemies of humanity are twofold in some
sense.
One is the chaos that comes from outside
and that disrupts the standard order and
that needs to be dealt with and the
other is the chaos that comes in the
inside when when our institutions and
hierarchies become corrupt,
and then the thing that transforms that
is the thing that has enough courage
either to stand up against the chaos or
to say something about the corrupt
institutions and what's happened as far
as I can tell is that over time,
those principles have been extracted out
from this much more embodied domain and
raise to the principle of highest
sovereignty.
Now,
one of the things that happened in Egypt
with called the dimock democratization
of Osiris and horus.
What seems to happen,
and this is this is what happened in
Egypt,
is that the power to manifest that
sovereignty.
I'd say is first only regarded as an
attribute of the sovereign like and the
king is actually only king in so far as
he could manifest that.
So in Mesopotamia,
you're only emperor.
If you were a good Marduk,
you'd go out on New Year's day and
reenact the entire cosmogony and you had
to be a good representative of Martech.
Otherwise you didn't deserve your
sovereignty and in Egypt,
unless you were a good Avatar,
let's say of Horus and Osiris,
the combination,
then you didn't get to be feral,
so you are embodying this principle,
this principle of sovereignty,
and what happened in Egypt was that
first of all,
the principle of sovereignty,
the images of sovereignty could only be
used by the Pharaoh and then it became
the aristocracy and then what seemed to
happen after that.
They were using the symbols.
What seemed to happen after that,
this was maybe a transmutation and part
via the Greeks and impart via the Jews,
is that the idea that that sovereignty
that was inherent in the Pharaoh and
then in the aristocracy was actually
something that could be attributed to
everyone that was human and that was I
think that that that manifested itself
most completely in some sense at the
beginning of the Christian era because
there was an emphasis then on the idea
that every single individual carried
within them a spark of the divine,
let's say,
and that was the proper source of
sovereignty,
and so then the question is,
well,
what is that source of the divine?
And that's why I read you that section
from John to begin with,
because the source of the divinity is
the capacity to speak and transmute the
world as a consequence of speaking.
And that's the proper principle of
sovereignty.
And as far as I can tell,
it's also the reason why in the west
people have an inviolable,
right?
The reason they have an inviolable right
is because our society figured out and
based on these unbelievably deep
antecedents,
print precedents that,
that
each individual had the capacity to
contribute something to the group
without which the group would be less.
It's something like that.
And so you're,
you're regarded at the base of our law
as the,
uh,
as the Avatar.
That's exactly right.
As the Avatar of a divine principle.
And that divine principle is the
capacity to use your speech to give
order to the chaos of the world and to
criticize structures of order that have
become corrupt and reformulate them.
And so you,
you have this territory that surrounds
you,
that's in violet,
that something about you that transcends
even the reach of the law,
which is a very strange thing,
you know,
because in our societies,
even if you're a murderer,
even if everyone knows it,
you still have inviolable rights.
You think of all the things that are
unlikely to have emerged as a concept.
That's got to be like number one.
It's been a very long,
long struggle for human beings to
understand that we embodied this
principle.
Let's say that continually generates the
world out of chaos and revitalizes,
it wouldn't becomes corrupt and dead and
that's the key as far as I can tell,
that's what's expressed in John is that
there isn't any difference between that
and the capacity to carefully articulate
the nature of your experience to other
people and then to respond to the
corrective feedback.
That's the way that human beings
progress through the world and that's
the ultimate principle.
That should be at the top of what I
think of as the set of all human
dominance hierarchies,
right?
Something will move you up.
Hierarchy,
something slightly different will move
you up a different hierarchy.
You'd take a huge set of hierarchies and
say,
well,
what's the principle that's going to
work best over across all those
hierarchies?
It's something like the capacity to
speak the truth,
and so that's how it looks to me and
that's why I think apart from the
practical reasons that already
described,
I know that's a tremendous amount of
information to process and I hope that
made some sense.
It's a very difficult thing to boil down
in a,
in a short period of time.
I mean,
I'd been trying to do that for like 30
years to get it coherent enough to
represented in a short period of time,
but there's the practical issue which is
that's how we encountered what we don't
understand and turn it into habitable
space and how we communicate about it
and reach consensus,
but then there's something much deeper
underneath that which is that we know
that and we know it really,
really deeply.
The whole human race is been aiming at
that for God only knows how long,
but it's hundreds of thousands of years
certainly.
And it might be far longer than that.
And so it's not a principle that we can
dispense with and assume that we'll
construct something.
Okay in this absence because it's
actually an expression of the
fundamental nature of human beings and
we mess with that are at our extreme
peril.
And as far as I can tell,
that's exactly what we're doing now.
So.
So that's part of the reason why
objected to bill [inaudible] because I
don't think that it's reasonable for
government authorities to put their God
damn words into their citizens mouth and
as simple as that,
I think there isn't,
there's almost nothing you could embark
on that would be more dangerous than
that.
And the fact that this had to do with
purportedly had to do with the rights of
a small minority of people I think is a
complete side show.
I think it's almost irrelevant in
relationship to the broader context.
And I think that if that wasn't the case
then there wouldn't have been any fear
whatsoever about what I said because who
the hell cares what I have to say?
So anyways,
that's my take on it.
So that's all I've got to say.
Thank you.
So.
So
you mentioned the form of dialogue.
So when you,
when you were giving a lecture,
you mentioned that you're not in fact
engaging in a monologue because by
looking and seeing her reactions,
you're constantly modifying your speech.
I was wondering if you could speak up
because I'm probably the only millennial
in this room or no,
no,
no.
One more,
one more.
Um,
but as someone who's kind of grown up in
the Internet and who in fact has social
media,
do you think sites like facebook and not
so much twitter,
but basically facebook,
do they stop this dialogue or how do
you,
what are the ramifications of such
things if people are communicating with
each other without really being in the
same room,
what for you is lost?
I think it's sort of analogous to the
danger of derivatives in the financial
market,
you know,
because like a derivative is something
that can amplify the degree to which the
market moves,
right?
Because it's an abstraction from the
underlying reality.
So it's more powerful for good and it's
more powerful for evil.
And I would say so to speak,
you know,
if you're thinking about it
metaphorically,
well it's an amplifier and that can be a
good thing,
but it can also be a bad thing.
And I think it does often amplify the
proclivity of people to disappear into a
self reflective bubble.
And that's aided by the algorithms that
feed to you what you want to see.
So and we don't know exactly what that's
going to do.
It's not a.
it's,
it's a very dangerous thing because
we're building an unconscious into the
internet and no one's going to
understand how it works because it gets
more and more complex,
especially when ai kicks in in a big way
because you can't understand how those
systems work even though they work.
And the problem with that unconscious in
the Internet is it filters information
and you don't know what the filtering is
mean.
You don't know what your own filtering
is,
you know,
because you're not conscious of your
underlying processes,
but this adds a whole new dimension to
it and the fact that it's self
fulfilling in some sense increases the
probability of positive feedback loops
that will go out of control.
Do you think that it kind of locks you
into your own,
maybe the story of Your Life?
Because I'm not afraid personally on a
frequent social media it I see it as no
people posting about themselves,
their other relationships.
Do you think it creates a constant
feedback loop that it's kind of like I'm
thinking of a would if this is the guy
that looks nice,
narcissists,
narcissists looking at your own
reflection in the mirror and not.
Well,
I think what happens is that you're not
allowing other.
I think that is a danger.
I also think though is that you also
fall prone to the implicit narcissism of
all the other facebook users and and
well because people generally post
glowing reviews of their own life and
you know,
to some degree that's understandable
because who wants to be subject to a
constant barrage of misery?
I mean there's reasons that people do
it.
They post themselves when they're having
fun when they're doing something
spectacular,
but that also means that you're being
blasted all the time by these endless
images of other people having a far
better time of life than you are.
And so I think that that we,
we do know that there is some evidence
that more exposure to facebook means
more depression.
Now it's hard to pull out correlation
and causality there,
but,
but then in the political sphere you
have the same problem because you're not
being fair and unbiased.
Sample of information and your own
initial biases are multiplied by the
algorithms that select for you what
you're going to look at and we don't
know.
We have no idea what the consequence of
that is,
so
thank you very much.
A incidentally,
I have a questions that concern
something similar,
but I'm talking about the real face to
face conversation.
You said how important it is for us as
speaker to get some feedback of your
audience.
Now,
having grown up in east Germany behalf
learned to look this,
no expression whatsoever.
It's the most outrageous stupid sinks
because the consequences of like rolling
your eyes Wednesday we're talking about
us being well ahead economically of
would be just very negative.
So we didn't do that and I see something
similar happening here in especially in
certain political lectures.
So if somebody tells you that what you
are doing or Taltz and audience,
what you are doing is horrible and I'm
in that audience.
I wouldn't roll my eyes because I know
what set.
So the consequences are now,
of course in
those are microaggressions.
Yeah.
Really.
I'm not kidding.
I mean,
that's exactly what it is.
The eye rolling in particular is a sign
of contempt.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
but of course if I,
if I never do that to you,
you now get the impressions that what
you say.
It's just wonderful.
So you don't get to critical feet at as,
as you pointed out,
a very important for you.
Yes.
Course said goals,
bolts,
waste.
So it's actually one of the on the
mental defenses of free speech is that
your dish,
if you constrain it,
you're depriving people of corrective
feedback and that's a very bad thing
because people,
people cannot maintain sanity in
isolation.
You,
you outsource your sanity to other
people.
If you're vaguely socially acceptable.
What that means is people can tolerate
having you around and then they will
provide you with corrective feedback and
as long as you react to that,
you don't have to worry about being sane
because they'll keep you way.
And you might think,
well no,
you can manage your sanity by yourself,
but no,
it's too complex.
You can't,
it's not possible.
So it's a problem.
It's not just inhibiting these speech
but also inhibiting a natural reaction
to speech.
Absolutely.
Well,
send the spontaneous reactions,
right?
Because a lot of those facial gestures,
those aren't,
those aren't precisely conscious and
that's actually good because they're
untrammeled expressions of your initial
instincts.
Something like that,
you know,
it's like having dogs around,
if you're agitated and upset,
the dog will get all nervous.
It's like,
well,
you can trust that the dog doesn't have
an agenda,
you know,
and people are like that in their
initial responses to.
Because that doesn't mean they're
correct,
but it at least it means that it's not
mediated by like an ideological bias or
not so straightforwardly.
Just before we hear from Eva,
I wanted to mention that,
uh,
we let our hypothesis die in our steps.
Karl Popper,
one of my favorite philosophers.
Copper.
Yes.
First of all,
I wanted to say thank you for most
interesting a presentation and online,
which a lot of us you haven't heard
before,
so thank you for that.
Uh,
and I've,
the two things that I wanted to ask you
about,
one,
the concept that you've enunciated of
the emergence over an extremely long
period of time,
of the idea that we all have somewhat of
the divine in us,
which I suppose also implies that we
have someone of the opposite as well.
Yeah.
It is hard.
That leads directly to the idea of
individual rights versus group,
right?
Yes.
And a lot of the troubles that all of us
here faced is that we have become the
target of,
uh,
these group demands for group,
right?
Rather than individual rights art or
attaining or not that
that march towards the higher
hierarchies of society based on our own
effort and our own performances and so
on.
So that's one.
But that's also the other side of
another thing that you raised,
which one really hears in any of these
kinds of meetings,
the biological basis of our behavior.
And I was really interested to hear you
bring this into the discussion because
it has seemed to me over the years,
and I've been around this business into
the sixties,
I think when it all troubled,
seemed to have started,
is that a lot of the feminism nonsense
is involved with the denial of
differences between males and females.
A lot of the problems with the
performance and affirmative action and
so on is the denial that there may be a
biological basis to some of the
performance differences that we see in
various
fields of activity around the world.
Uh,
and also this idea that we can decide
what gender we are tomorrow morning and
that I,
I must say I'd never heard of this.
So what did you call it,
the,
the Gender Unicorn and I will do when I
go and the instructor olds and six year
old will be subjected to this is
positively alarming.
So I just asked you to comment
here.
Well,
the,
they call that biological essentialism,
right?
And so that's a,
that's a,
that's a curse word essentially,
right?
If so,
and again,
that's partly why I objected to the
legislation and surrounding policy
because it doesn't allow for a
biological influence and so which is
preposterous in my estimation and mean
the biology actually is much more useful
than people even realize.
So you know,
one of the things we were talking about
earlier today was say the distinction
between conservatives and liberals.
I can tell you one of the things that
produces right wing authoritarianism.
It's very interesting and you wouldn't
guess this in a million years.
Prevalence of infectious disease.
So there was a great paper published
three years ago.
It was brilliant prevalence of
infectious disease.
So it was published in a journal called
plause one and these researchers were
interested in this hypothesis called the
behavioral immune system.
And so you know very frequently when
here too,
for isolated human groups come into
contact that either one group or the
other dies,
like maybe,
maybe all of them are virtually all of
them.
That's essentially what happened to the
native Americans when the Spaniards hit
Central America.
Right?
Because they didn't have any built in
immunity to smallpox or chicken pox or
mumps or measles and like success of
epidemics just wiped them out.
The estimates vary,
but it could be as high as 95 percent
and so it appears as though the border
idea,
the idea of thick borders,
let's say,
which is a fundamentally conservative
idea.
The liberals want open borders and a lot
of information flow in the conservatives
want closed borders and more restriction
and protection at every level of the of
the conceptual hierarchy.
It's not just political borders,
its borders around everything,
but that seems to be tightly associated,
at least in part with the prevalence of
infectious disease both at the country
level and at the,
at the local level within countries and
the correlations like point seven.
It's not trivial and it's not with
governmental authoritarian attitudes.
It's with individual authoritarian
attitudes at in the locales where
they're infectious diseases are
prevalent and it seems to be associated
with the emotion of disgust,
so Hitler wasn't afraid of the Jews.
Conservatives aren't afraid of others.
That isn't how it works.
They're disgusted.
That's not the same thing.
It's associated with a personality trait
called orderliness and so hit re once
this has been sorted out by
psychologists over about the last 10
years,
let's say,
and what when I was plowing through the
literature and working on the
relationship between disgust,
sensitivity and personality,
I happened to reread Hitler's table
talk,
which was a collection of his
spontaneous speeches collected at
dinnertime,
lunchtimes by secretaries from 1939 to
1942 and one.
Once I knew this other information,
it just leapt out at me,
you know,
so Hitler was a admirer of willpower
that makes them a conscientious type of
person,
very obsessed with order,
washed his hands,
continually was hyper clean and disgust
sensitive.
And his primary metaphor for the German
people was a body area in body pure body
under assault by parasites.
It's pure disgust and contamination
language and it's mediated by disgust
sensitivity.
And that's one of the things that
predicts that kind of right wing,
close the border attitude.
And that's also heightened in places
where infectious diseases are a real
problem.
So if you want to eliminate right wing
authoritarianism,
it actually looks like one of the things
you could do is as promote public health
programs everywhere to rid the world of
the,
to the degree that that's possible of
infectious diseases.
Well you know,
you want to impede the flow between
people if there's infectious diseases
everywhere obviously.
And that manifests itself in political
attitudes.
So there's the biology reaches way
deeper than than people are willing to
like to assume.
But some of the things that it tells us
are unbelievably useful to know,
being terrible to know in some sense,
but useful to know.
And so I'd like the walls work on,
on the stability of,
of primate hierarchies.
Incredibly important.
I mean he's been looking at the
emergence of protocol morality among
chimpanzees and that seems to be driven
in large part by the dominance hierarchy
structure.
And it's not exactly a dominance
hierarchy either.
That's probably not exactly the right
way to think about it because,
you know,
dominance implies pure power,
but lots of human hierarchies aren't
dominance hierarchies and all their
competence hierarchies or something like
that.
So it's very different.
I'm a libertarian,
so I favor of freedom,
but unlike a lot of libertarians,
I don't think that there's kind of a
natural affinity to freedom among human
beings that evolution has actually
trained us to be conformists much more
than freedom loving individualists
absolute.
And,
and as a result of that,
uh,
I mean because,
because in our evolutionary history,
it was often much more important to row
all in the same direction.
The clan,
you know,
the roughly
related,
genetically related clans that were
roaming the,
it was much more important to row in the
same direction than to row in the right
direction.
As long as you didn't roll off the off
the cliff or run off the cliff,
that would be bad.
But,
but as long as you were muddling
through,
it was better for everyone to be in the
same.
And so therefore we evolve to be very
much conformists and people like you.
And to lesser extent,
the rest of us in this room are the
disruptors were the ones who are
nonconformist were the ones who say,
Hey,
wait a minute,
that doesn't sound right to me.
And,
and we're the ones who want to lead
society back to chaos,
the state of chaos where everyone's got
their own little little view of how
things should go instead of following
the leader and just doing what everyone
else does.
And that's why people like you attract
to meet to my way of thinking.
That's why people like you attract such
a visceral,
angry reaction is that you're,
you're leading us back into chaos and if
we don't all ignore you and shut you
down and you know,
we're all going to be,
you know,
in the state where the clan is fighting
amongst each other instead of rowing in
the same direction.
If you have any thoughts on that.
Well,
I think certainly one of the things I've
learned,
see,
I already knew before all this happened
that people were primarily conforming
and I actually don't have much of a
problem with that because most of the
time the tradition is correct,
but sometimes it's not correct at all.
That's the problem is that.
So you know,
one of the things I always tell my
clients and my students for that matter
is you should do what everyone else does
unless you have a really good reason to
vary.
And one of the things I learned from
young Carl young was that,
and if you do very,
you should try to only do it in a couple
of directions because you probably can't
handle doing it more than that.
It's just too much to too much
psychologically.
But you know,
the problem is,
is that sometimes the group is rolling
off a cliff and then it's then you know,
that's partly why the individual in some
senses the eternal savior of the group
because the group is.
It has the aspect of sheep,
let's say,
and the sheep are doing fine.
They've got the whole herd thing going
for them,
decreases the risk of individual
predation.
They've got all their nervous systems in
tune.
So there's real utility in the herd,
but they're also subject to all the
problems that herds have like heard
panic or.
And so.
So that's not good enough.
That's what human beings figured out was
that being part of the herd,
although necessary,
isn't good enough.
There has to be a balance between the
tradition,
the old dead tradition and the vivifying
force of the,
of the,
a lot of the living essentially that's
those are actually how the gods split up
and need you.
Because Horace was roughly a
representation of the living and it was
cyrus was roughly a representation of
the dead and it was the combined
combination of those two that made up
the sovereign very intelligent,
like dramatic political philosophy.
So,
but you know,
one of the things I have seen since
September is,
I mean I knew that people were
conformance,
but I really had.
I really had no idea to what degree that
was true.
You know,
like,
I mean I've got very,
very,
very few letters of support from people
who are academics for example.
And they get secret reports.
Really.
You know,
people will come and say,
well we agree with what you're doing,
but we wish you could be a little nicer
about it.
Which,
which,
you know,
it's a funny thing for people to say
because it implies that if they did what
I was doing,
they would do a better job,
you know,
which is fine,
but you know,
you can always try it out and see how it
goes.
So
when I gave talks in
equity,
one of the most common comments I would
get after the thing's over and people
that are milling around and shaking your
hand is,
I agree with everything you said that I
would never say.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
it's no wonder it's not,
it's not surprising,
you know,
I mean,
there are real reasons not to stick out
from the herd.
If you,
if you mark a zebra so that you can
identify it against the herd,
the lions will kill it.
Right?
And that's that Ban Italia.
No one that you like because they can't,
they can't organize their haunted less.
They can identify the individual lines
dazzled.
That's right,
while they're camouflaged against the
herd zebras.
So that's,
man,
that's worth knowing.
It explains a lot that.
Oh,
sorry.
Thanks very much for elaborating.
Very,
uh,
very compellingly.
The fundamental significance of thought
and speech are almost impossible to,
at our point in development to two
separate,
um,
and uh,
the,
the trans issue,
which is the particularity that isn't
very important.
And,
you know,
I,
I would agree with you,
but I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a sex researcher,
so people are going to ask me,
uh,
the Trans Issue I think is an
appropriate lightening rod for social
constructionism.
Uh,
and you know,
as a,
as a researcher in this field,
I can tell you that John Money was
wrong.
Kids aren't Tabula Rosa and you know,
Micky diamond was right and,
you know,
etc. And now you're in trouble.
YeAh.
The presence,
the presence of police officers here was
actually a very interesting,
um,
uh,
underscoring of the power of thought and
speech and the millennial issue of the
internet,
uh,
reminds us that we don't choose our
audience.
Uh,
in the internet.
you're basically exposed to the world,
uh,
and you're a tendency to self center to
avert being trolled is probably great.
At any rate,
um,
that's just,
just,
just background.
My colleagues are going to,
my,
uh,
my colleague,
ken zucker,
who,
one of your colleagues at the university
of toronto was recently fired for his
departure from common wisdom and it
wasn't much of a departure and in fact,
he represents common wisdom on the
trance phenomena.
Having said all that,
mY colleagues are going to ask you two
questions,
uh,
asked me two questions.
If he meT joan who was trans feminine,
you know,
male to female transsexual,
would you refer to her as joan?
Okay.
It's simpler.
And the other issue is midst all the
garbage and the hype and the let's
reassigned a three year old and,
you know,
stuff that I think all of us would
regard as nonsense.
Um,
many of us in some of us in this room
deal with trans individuals every day.
You know,
like,
uh,
some gay individuals,
that's just the way they,
they,
they emerged in life.
Uh,
they're genuine.
They're not particularly begging special
privilege.
Uh,
my colleagues get to say,
would you,
you know,
you'd call her joan and would you,
would you accord her authenticity or
reality or whereas she socially
constructing herself or was she born
that way?
Well,
the devil's always in the details.
You know,
I mean,
one of the things that's emerging right
now,
although this is a fringe viewpoint,
is like imagine that you're dating
while you prejudiced
because people's prejudices shine forth
most clearly in their choice of
partners,
right?
They choose people who are.
Sorry,
oh,
people's prejudice is shine forth most
brightly in their choice of,
of,
of sexual partners,
right?
We prefer young people.
Generally speaking,
we prefer healthy people.
We prefer people of our own race.
We prefer people of our own religion.
We prefer high,
the highest performing individuals we
can get our hands on generally speaking.
And so the whole that steeply
prejudicial and one of the things that's
emerging,
I wouldn't say in the trans community
because there isn't such a thing as far
as I can tell,
but among certain individuals is they're
dubious of your right to choose your
sexual partner based on their genitalia,
let's say.
Because that's a form of discrimination,
so yeah.
Well,
you know,
look,
I can tell you in,
in huxley's brave new world,
and this is where thinking about you
didn't get to you was,
it was a social full part.
It turned down as sexual request because
it's discriminatory.
It's like,
well,
it is discriminatory.
Really.
I'm not kidding man.
It's the deepest form of discrimination,
you know,
you're basically saying you're basically
saying yes,
exactly.
That's exactly it.
And that's what you had to do in
huxley's brave new world.
And you also weren't allowed to have a
long term monogamous relationship
because the exclusionary element of that
was regarded as prejudicial,
which it is.
That's the thing.
And so the question is,
well,
uh,
I could say,
well,
I would,
I wouldn't discriminate.
It's like,
well,
it depends on exactly what you mean by
discriminate.
And then of course the argument is about
exactly what,
right?
I have to discriminate.
And increasingly the answer is none.
Like we've already sacrificed freedom of
assembly.
We're pretty much on the way to a
sacrificing freedom of speech.
It's a logical conclusion to all of this
that
I'm going to be asked by colleagues,
what is your view of the authenticity
that is
always identified as the opposite gender
now have much better that I've
transitioned.
Yes.
Well,
that's a part that I'm more skeptical
about because the evidence isn't all
that clear,
that people do feel better when they
transition.
So,
but it's.
Look,
it's.
Yes,
it is.
First of all,
there's the fact that there are
categories doesn't mean there aren't
exceptions.
There's exceptions now what those
exceptions signify?
Well that's generally to be dealt with
on an individual to individual basis and
that's fine with me.
You know,
I'm a clinician,
I've dealt with all sorts of people who
don't and who fits in the categories.
Nobody like to become socialized.
What you do is you mangle your square
peg into a round hole and,
and I mean for some people it's
obviously far more of a sacrifice than
for others,
but you know,
social being demands,
what would you call restriction of your,
at least have your individuality and all
sorts of different aspects.
And for some people,
that's much more of a sacrifice than
others.
The question is,
what does the existence of the exception
imply for the general case?
And I believe that if you're a
postmodernist and a marxist underneath
that it supplies the excuse to take down
the category of gender and why would you
do that?
Well,
It's a category used by the oppressive
patriarchy to continue.
It's to continue.
It's pathological power seeking
distinction between no,
leave me alone.
I want to get on with my life versus
the category so that there's room for
yes precisely,
or I'm going to dismiss the category on
behalf of someone else who I claim to
speak for,
which is even more commonly the case
general environment where oppression and
identity are the currency of status and
advantage.
Yes.
Right,
right.
Well,
and I just don't see that it's going to
be all that useful.
Kids are confused enough when they're
growing up.
I think to add gender confusion to that,
which we're doing very,
very rapidly is going to destroy 15
people.
For every one it saves.
It might be more than that because
there's plenty of confused people out
there,
I would say like what?
Two out of 30,
something like that are just barely
clinging onto the to the edges of
reality and they're looking for
acceptance and transmutation wherever
they can find it and confusing them
further isn't going to help and these
people that were transitioning young,
there's going to be one hell of a
kickback from that.
I can tell yoU when they hit the,
when they hit adulthood.
Let me just follow up on grant brown's
question.
Jordan is among the top fIve or top 10
professors in north America during the
past year who's been a lightning rod,
a target of collective efforts at
humiliation and being disgraced.
And mY question is essentially if you
could give as parsimonious answer as you
can,
which generally isn't very personable,
I've noticed.
Yes,
of why you.
and it's a remarkable phenomenon,
uh,
when somebody is demonized to the extent
that you have been in mainstream media.
I was reading just lately.
I've picked up in a carpet can ix office
a copy of toronto life.
Oh yeah.
There was this nice job by,
by,
uh,
a kind of wide eyed reporter,
you know,
he doesn't seem like a demon know,
he seems like a kind of nice guy.
He even seems a little bit on the left,
but he,
he must be a demon there somewhere.
So the question is just as briefly as
you can why you.
Because I said there was some
I wouldn't do
right.
I mean because like all these massive
ideas,
as I said,
they manifest themselves in micro
examples,
you know,
many micro examples,
but they're micro examples and so
there's always a certain amount of
arbitrary penis when you decided to not
go along with it.
And the arbitrary ness is like,
well,
I said that I wouldn't use these words
for example,
and had a rationale for it.
And then people test you out when you,
when you put up your hand,
they test you out.
They think,
well,
are you just a monster?
Well let's throw a bunch of monster
words at you and see if they stick.
See if you can defend yourself because
that's a really good way of finding out
whether you're actually a monster,
and so that was the first,
let's say two months of all of this was
me just sort of fending off these
different accusations.
Now.
I was fortunate in many ways.
I was fortunate in that in the first
demonstrations that followed the the
videos that the people who were
supporting me behaved reasonably well
compared to the people who weren't.
Now you could think about that as
somewhat dependent on chance.
Not entirely,
but things could have gone badly the
other way and also I was protected by
the fact that I already had about 400
hours of videos online and so virtually
everything I had said to students in the
last well over the span of 30 years
really,
but particularly in the last five years,
was all recorded.
And so if anybody wanted to find out if
I was a monster,
all they had to do is go through the
painful process of listening to what I
had to say and there were no smoking
guns buried in there,
which is,
which is significant.
Given that there were 200 hours of it,
you know,
it's,
you'd think there'd be something in
there that I said that could have been
taken out of context that would have
really walled me a good one,
but so far nobody seems to have
extracted so.
And I also think that.
I guess the next reason would be I
didn't,
just apart from saying there was
something specific I wouldn't do,
which brings the abstraction down to a
point of reality,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's a line that,
that makes it real rather than just an
abstract critique.
I think the other thing thAt happened
was that people came to my website
because of the political material,
but that isn't where they stopped.
They started listening to what I had to
say and I think that what I have to say
is actually revolutionary.
So.
And I think people have a sense of that.
I mean,
it looks like it as far as I can tell,
the response seems to indicate that.
And,
you know,
I shared some of that with you today
that the idea that some of our values
are grounded in,
in phenomena that are far more
primordial,
let's say,
then our mere opinion,
like that's a big deal.
If it's,
if there's anything about it that's
true.
And I mean,
I don't know,
but I've been trying to puzzle this out
for a long time and uh,
it seems to cohere and when people try
to apply the principles that I've been
discussing in their lives,
it makes their lives better.
You know?
And it's so interesting too because I've
been going around speaking publicly,
you know,
and most of my audience is men,
interestingly enough,
even in the live talks and all I've been
doing with the man basically is talking
to them about saying what's true and
adopting responsibility.
And they're so bloody hungry for that.
That is just mind boggling,
you know,
which is something really curious and
interesting to me because that's not a
saleable message.
You know,
it's,
it's because are basically saying,
well,
find the heaviest load you can conceive
of and try to pick it up.
And while you're doing that,
you know,
try to engage in the least amount of
deceit as possible and that that's also
a pathway out of suffering for people in
general.
Well,
it's so interesting to see how
unbelievably positively the people who
who are following this are responding.
They're responding to that.
It's,
I've been talking to a lot of the
potential leaders of the conservative
party and you know,
one of the things I've told them
repeatedly is you guys have something to
sell young people for the first time
that I can remember.
And that's responsibility.
The left is selling freedom and rights.
It's like,
well yeah,
where's the other half of the story
freedom.
That's freedom to drown.
I mean,
I've got nothing against freedom
obviously,
but there's no rights without
responsibilities and there's no freedom
without tradition.
So somebody's got to tell the other half
of the story.
So Dr. Peterson three more questions.
Is that okay?
We don't want to wear you down.
Sure.
Okay.
That's,
you're too late for that.
Thanks a lot Jordan.
I'm remembering a conversation we had
about a month ago.
Yep.
Cafe in ottawa.
And some of the issues we discussed then
brought up again today.
Uh,
it leads to certain we didn't resolve
anything.
I think ultimately,
and I doubt if we ever will,
and it seems to me the real problem is
something you mentioned today.
We could go a little further with it.
It's the question that's pontius pilots
question,
the first postmodernist what is truth?
And it was taken up many times,
but by nature and the genealogy of
morals were all truth is interpretation.
And of course this is not the case with
nisha and anybody who follows him,
as you pointed out,
because that's somebody else's truth,
that there is no truth and therefore
what do you do with that?
And you're into the problem of the creek
and liar.
But here is the problem for me even with
your talk,
which is as usual,
brilliant and I think grounded and in
tremendous amount of factual
information.
I was asked once a,
after a book of mine came out,
which was contested hockley by many
people.
What gave me the right to think I had
the truth.
This was an interviewer in toronto for
the random house thing and why did I
think what I was saying was true.
Who was I to say that I had the truth
and I said,
I don't have the truth,
and I had to come up with some
explanation quickly in some kind of
phrase and it just occurred to me.
I said,
all I have is this credible
verisimilitude.
What is credible?
Various similitude.
He wanted to know.
I said a,
it depends on gathering as much evidence
as you possibly can,
even if you have to counter your own
biases.
You just said with as least the least
amount of deceit or self indulgence as
possible,
and the second factor is common sense,
which seems to be not so common these
days.
So if you can put evidence and coMmon
sense together and at the same time try
and marshall and monitor your own
proclivities.
I went right,
but that was hard with my book as I was
left before I could go right and I had
to make that decision.
Do I want to go right and lose all my
friends or do I want to stay left and
you know,
have catholic men and joy my friends and
saw I had to go right?
Because that's what the evidence told me
against my own desires.
So honesty,
if you can manage it,
evidence and common sense,
but here's the problem.
Truths.
It's still there.
How do you get from credible?
Uh,
various similitude to truth.
Where is the bridge?
How do you get there?
Nobody can say that ultimately,
yes,
but the problem I think you can,
you can say certain things are true.
Certain dates,
etc. Etc.
Certain things have happened for men
have suffered as a result of feminism.
All this is true,
but we're truth seems to founder is when
you enter the realm of cars who has the
truth to explain why feminism developed
in the way it did,
or why climate warming or global warming
developed in the way in d did.
We can point out the facts.
This is wrong,
this is wrong,
this is happening.
But when you get out of the element,
the region of events and into the region
of the cause of his,
that's the bridge,
the gap from credible verisimilitude to
truth,
and I franKly don't know how to manage
that.
So the conclusion I'm coming to is a
little bit different from your
conclusion.
It's not the one that I want to come to
and I would like to resist it,
but the conclusion I'm coming to is
quite simply,
we're fucked.
Yes.
But that's always been true,
right?
The apocalypse is always.
That's why the apocalypse is eternal
because the world's always coming to an
end and it's actually true in small ways
and in great ways.
I mean with regards to to your,
your ideas about truth.
I would say that like language truth is
more like a process.
And I would say it's,
it's,
it's a process that you actually
embodied rather than conceptualiZe
abstractly to.
One of the ways I've thought about it is
that if you're seeking the truth and
what you don't know is more important to
you than what you know.
And that's a fundamental orientation,
right?
I mean,
what I'm doing,
what I've been doing since september,
and I've had friends who've been helping
me with this,
but I think I've been doing this for a
long time as I'm trying to figure out
where I'm wrong.
I'm watching the audience to see if I'm
making mistake.
I'm listening to my friends who were
watching my youtube videos telling me
what I'm a little too angry maybe or
maybe too pompous or too noisy,
or you know,
all the different ways that you can fail
in front of an audience.
I'm listening to them and listening to
the comments and I'm trying to modify
myself accordingly.
You know,
and so you live in error and strive
towards the truth and it's in that
striving that the truth is most
accurately embodied.
But then I would also say one other
thing,
and this is what I like about the
existentialists,
is that,
you know,
there's,
there's a kind of emphasis on pragmatic
truth among the existentialists because
they claim that your truth is something
that you should act out not merely hold.
Because to act out is to believe that
it's a definition,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's not,
it's not precisely a proposition,
it's a definition.
And so I've found some things that I was
confident in enough into risk acting out
and so that's what I'm doing to the best
of my ability and then I'm watching what
happens and,
and I'm watching what happens if other
people act oUt the propositions and w as
far as I can tell.
So far so good.
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I wouldn't say that my position right
now is to be,
what would you envied?
It's very stressful.
I mean since september I basically be an
imposition of
any misTake is fatal for,
for all intents and purposes,
you know,
and that's very stressful to be that
hypervigilant and uh,
but by the same token,
the public response to what I've been
doing has been overwhelmingly positive.
You know,
I've only got three pieces of hate mail
which,
which just staggers me,
you know,
and,
and the comments on youtube for example,
are,
are like 50 to one positive and I mean,
who,
yeah,
maybe it's a biased sample.
I can't tell,
but,
and the other thing,
you know,
I'd been trying to rip holes in the
ideas that I presented to you today for
really like with all my intellectual
capability for as long.
Every time I lecture I'm trying to do
the same thing is like,
is there something in this that I
haven't got right?
Because I'm trying.
I was trying to look for some,
a rock at the bottom of things,
you know,
and partly why I decided that I wasn't
going to use those damn words is because
I think the rock at the bottom of things
is honest speech.
I really believed that it seems to me to
be right and
that's good enough.
So I'll act it out and see what happens
as best I can.
I mean,
I'm not claiming to be.
I'm not claiming to be any more honest
than anyone else.
You know?
Seriously,
I'm not.
I did that.
That's a big claim to make you better
watch your bloody step if you're going
to say that,
but that doesn't mean I don't believe
that on a speech is the pathway to
redemption because I do believe that.
So I know that's strange language,
but you know,
that's still,
it's the most accurate language for that
kind of conceptualization.
So
during your presentation,
your,
your emphasis is always been on the
truth.
I mean,
um,
the,
the man who strays from the group to
find the truth and comes back to it,
etc. Oh,
I'm,
his emphasis has been throughout on
truth.
And my question is this,
I take it that truth is a necessary
condition for an idea being important at
some level.
It's not at all obvious and it's a
sufficient condition.
I mean,
some truths are surely uninteresting,
boring.
Um,
and others are really important.
And,
and in particular,
ideas about value.
Now,
I'm not sure whether you wanted to
classify claims about value as being
susceptible of truth or falsity.
That's sort of been a long standing,
you know,
questioning the philosophical world,
but uh,
but which is the right thing to say
about those,
but let's,
if we suppose that we include those,
it would be a way of,
of,
uh,
obscuring the contrast I'm pointing to
make,
which is surely we need an additional
variable which is the value of these
ideas and it's not.
I was wondering whether you were in,
we're supposing that you had at least
implicitly some kind of general
criterion of value of that kind that
applies in your theory or whether that's
open ended.
No,
I have a criteria because it didn't.
I mean that's a fundamental question and
I am talking about values rather than
empirical facts of which there are an
infinity right.
And so it's tHe application of the facts
to the problems of life.
That's the,
that's the problem because there's a lot
of facts,
but I would say,
and I got this partly from piaget
because cpa,
one of the things that jumped piaget was
trying to do is to understand.
He was actually trying to mediate
between religion and science.
That's what drove his entire
intellectual career and he came up with
this idea of the aquilla braided state,
which is an idea I really liked,
so imagine two teams of five people
pursuing a goal.
it's the same goal for both teams,
but team a has been forcibly compelled
to attain the goal and team b is doing
it voluntarily.
his proposition was is that in a,
in an even in a race,
that was even all other things
considered that the team that was
composed of voluntary participants would
outperform the team that was compelled
and I believe that ben and he and he
basically said it's enforcement costs
that make the difference and that's a
compelling argument for me and so I've
been expanding on that.
Partly it's like piaget via young I
would say is the intellectual pathway.
It's like the,
the,
the proper aim for value is something
like what's good for me in a way that's
good for me tomorrow and next week and
next month and next year because
timeframe matters a lot,
so that's a serious constraint and then
what's good for me now and the future me
in a way that's also good for the other
people around me,
if that's possible,
and then also broader society if that's
possible across multiple time frames and
that sort of like the ultimate
equilibrated state.
And so that's a hypothetical ideal
obviously,
but
a
number of things which are,
which are good,
that same criteria but different.
Lots of them,
we don't want to get it right,
but a sort of single criteria,
well I know,
but I think
take it to graduate and that filters
out.
Yeah.
But it leaves a whole lot of it in and
that's interesting and I think that's a
good thing myself,
but certainly it's not obvious that that
wouldn't be true.
I think there's commonalities among the
set of solutions.
That's basically,
that's the proposition that I'm putting
forward is that there are.
And I think those would be akin to
young's archetypes.
There are commonalities across the sets
of solutions and so,
and they're reflective of people's,
I would say basic nature,
roughly speaking.
I mean it's partly why human beings that
are isolated and have been forever can
learn to trade with one another for
example,
because they can.
And so there's,
there's,
there are constraints built into that
requirement that I just described that
weed out most solutions,
which also I think the answer
to the postmodern dilemma,
which is well because you're kind of
posing it,
which is well,
how do you know there isn't an
indefinite number of solutions.
And I would say because the,
the,
the constraints on the solution space
are so intense that very few variance
manage.
Because if you make a big mistake,
your dad or people or people gang up on
you or like you know,
you either run into the world headlong
and parish or you transgressed against
your fellow people and they are not very
happy about that.
And so the set of solutions that allows
you to simultaneously exist in the world
and in the social world for a reasonable
length of time there,
I think there's a very limited number of
solutions to that problem.
It Just seems to be
in your universe in a way that
restricts.
What's that?
Well,
I mean,
the only thing I can say is that,
that I think there are a set of
solutions that bounded in some manner,
even though it may be quite large,
but there's still a pattern to be
detected among.
It's like,
it's like the pattern that you can
detect that unites everything that's
musical.
You know,
there's something,
although there's very diverse forms of
music,
there's something that emerges from all
those forms that allows you to generate
the category.
And I think the same is the case with
ethical behavior,
although even though it's subject to the
constraints of time and place as well.
So.
Well,
thanks very much Jordan.
This was really a great presentation
that you've done.
I wanted to end with some encouragement.
First of all,
I've looked at the extent of your
coverage on youtube and one of my areas
is digital media and journalism and it's
incredibly impressive as you probably
already know.
So the level of influence that you have
is really incredible and that's a good
thing because that brings me to my
second point.
I've watched a lot of your stuff and
you're not embarrassing for those of us
who hold similar views.
Great,
great.
That's good.
I am.
I'm,
I am definitely.
In fact,
I mean there are a lot of people who
espouse similar views and they give me
shivers.
They get,
they make me sick to my stomach a bit,
but you haven't embarrassed us,
me and that's good.
And secondly,
I've seen that you have moderated even
your approach as saying the same things,
but you become even more erudite and the
way that you present your arguments and,
and I really appreciate the effort that
you're putting into this because the
number of places that you've been and
the number of shows that you've appeared
on,
I know must be very tax taxing.
And so I want to just acknowledge that
you're doing this not for your own good
and I really the effort that you're
putting into this because this is a lot
of personal effort that you've expended
and I really appreciate it.
Yes,
thank you.
Because this is the question.
The question is,
I've heard a story everyone,
but the question is this,
I keep hearing people say if,
and these are my colleagues who are
cowards incidentally who say if only he
were nicer.
And you've mentioned that already.
Do you really think that an honestly,
this is the question then,
do we need to be nicer?
Do you need to be nicer?
What really?
Just the response to that if you would.
I need to be nicer when it's necessary
to be nice and not nicer when it isn't
and I need to learn to distinguish those
more carefully,
continually more carefully and ho
hypothetically.
I'm getting better at it.
The fact that my job isn't at stake at
the moment actually does take some of
the agitation pressure off.
You know?
I mean,
at the beginning of this I was quite
embattled,
let's say,
and also less
accustomed to this crazy sequence of
events and so,
you know,
I didn't know exactly what I was doing,
not that I do now,
but I'm,
and I'm more resigned to it in some
sense as well,
and I'm not trying to present myself as
you know,
I don't regard what's happened to me as
any sort of calamity even though it's
very complicated,
but it has its own momentum and,
and that's okay,
I guess,
but I'm,
I'm trying to
weave my way through this with the least
amount of enmity possible.
Right.
But that's something you have to
continually feel out and hopefully
that's working better.
That's the plan.
Thanks.